i like that you're doing a tribute to
chris cornell and particularly uh the
song seasons
yeah this is i think one of his best
songs he wrote this song you know
yeah i know he wrote the song and and
it's i love
this is probably my favorite chris
cornell song right i think with maybe
is it all of our favorite chris cornell
songs right and it's not the one you say
uh
black hole son or something like that
but that's the but but
known probably but seasons seasons is
it was on the soundtrack so it was
that's another thing too is on the
soundtrack for
singles which i think is one of the best
soundtracks of all time it's an amazing
soundtrack it's amazing it was like the
music that was happening at the time
you know and the music that we all love
so much all that pearl jam stuff and
yeah um
a lot of different artists but also a
lot of old music too like there's some
hendrix on that and some zeppelin even
too right yeah
i think it's just the best soundtrack
ever and then seasons which
which really like wasn't a big kind of
chris cornell song other than the fact
that it was in the movie and at the time
it was pretty big but
no one talks about that song as much
james uh that the the tuning of this
song
what is it it's a weird tuning weird 2d
it's only two notes so it's
f c c c c f
which is you know for guitar players
they know that's a pretty weird tuning
so so when chris cornell wrote this he
had his guitar tuned to a weird tuning
and there's a lot of them too so we have
three acoustics today
yeah now by the way we have sam uh jesse
and james on guitars they all have
acoustic guitars
why does this song take three guitars
guys explain this to me since i'm not a
guitar player
well the recording the recording i think
does have three right it is
yeah i think it's all it's all him over
dubbing himself so we're just recreating
the record
yeah so when he comes you know it's it's
a very simple part right
it's a very simple not that simple but
there's a lot of different things that
make it sound better double certain
guitars here there you bring things in
and out so
we wanted to be authentic today so today
we are being authentic we're being
authentic
what should we think right now we should
we should think about chris cornell we
should think about what a great talent
he was we should think about the world
we should think about uh when he wrote
this this guy when i was
falling in love with music he was he was
extraordinary one of your influences
yes he was all right i'm going to shut
up now i'm going to let you boys do your
thing i'm not going to jump in on this
song i could but i won't
yeah if i do that you'll stop all right
do your thing
please i'm gonna think about chris
cornell you got it me too
one two three four
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
summer night's a long
[Music]
a mirror shows another faith
another place to hide it all
another place to hide it all
and i'm lost
behind
the words i'll never find
[Music]
the seasons
[Music]
for my head
dreams have never been the answer
and dreams will never make
my bed
dreams have never made my bed
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
seasons
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
feathers in the rainbow
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
if i should be sure
[Music]
could you call into
[Music]
myself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]